the daily hustle on the streets of Kabul
takes a toll on people mainly struggling
to make ends meet some just to get
through one day but in another part of
the city secured behind concrete walls
Afghan politicians continue to bigger
five months after the election incumbent
President Ashraf Ghani was declared
winner by the controversial Electoral
Commission which pushed his rival and
chief executive of the outgoing
government Abdullah Abdullah to announce
that he will also form his own
government that is true but as we are
talking right now there is an
opportunity to tackle this issue and
find a reasonable solution for the
political crisis if not yes we had
announced that we will go ahead with our
emigration dr. Abdullah firmly believes
that according to the biometrically
verified votes he has won the election
the two men already had a power-sharing
agreement brokered by the United States
in a national unity government that was
all but united it's nothing new for the
Afghans less than 20 percent of the
registered voters took part in the past
election many didn't because of the
insecurity in their areas but many
others simply because they lost faith in
their leaders and ask anyone now they
would tell you they are more preoccupied
with the upcoming peace deal between the
US and the Taliban then who will become
their next president it's also the
priority for the White House after
months of negotiations in Qatar the
peace agreement between the u.s. and the
Taliban could be derailed by
Washington's long-standing allies in
Afghanistan the next step subsequently
will be the intra African dialogue the
vitally crucial and Travon dialogue now
who do we have who can represent the
Afghan side at the end chart and
dialogue when they go and sit with the
Taliban now for the international
community in the United States our
specific
and the problem is defragmentation in
Kabul the Taliban agreed to a
confidence-building deal to reduce
violence for seven days they are seen to
have respected the agreement with the
Americans even though there have been
multiple attacks around the country
targeting Afghan security forces
portfolio the father the Taliban did not
agree to a complete ceasefire because it
could lose its power on the ground but
this deal shows our flexibility we were
wise and we agreed to this reduction of
violence period so no one could blame us
the u.s. seems to have put a temporary
stop to the infighting Ashraf Ghani is
now set to be inaugurated on March 9th
but the political divisions in Kabul are
now the biggest challenge for ending
America's longest war and bringing the
peace Afghans have been aspiring to for
decades heard abdel hamid al jazeera
kibou